[Music]
my supervisor she basically allowed me
to be a personal assistant to have mine
cast who's a writer and a feminist and
it was really amazing to have that
opportunity
highlights it is an easy little thing or
money to keep everything that I got to
do that's just been different from
anything that I've ever done before
come on the beauty of it else the
seminoles don't search in their canoe
Brittany civilization so when you put
the banana on the travail and another
con say e komo you pull back to me don't
be afraid to speak up don't be afraid to
ask for help don't be afraid to like ask
to learn as well there are certain
things I guess in the office how things
are like don't be afraid they're like
challenged and if I change the truth of
the movie did it maybe you see it's not
safe out there
when I did a joke on this - because of
the Michael Campbell CD changer
we're more autonomous on Foxhall I don't
how to use Excel finally managing the
workload because somebody's to get a lot
of things to get done and enough to get
to be really quick
I definitely improved upon the things
that I already know being exposed to the
environment the food found on tonight
this fish then you know the scale of the
work that we do the cultural aspects the
educational aspects are amazing so and
it's great to be at the heart of I don't
know that the on its do you see the
coolest Akiko's new you know they could
chill kidneys we see don't suspect about
composers me I actually never heard of
it before I got here and then when I get
here if I know we're in like dozens of
countries and world I was like oh big
deal
so I guess my my perception has change
it's a fact that like I know it exists
and it that way it's really important
and they do a lot of good work
the original person who was supposed to
buy the emails was away so they told me
to ask Bob Lewis when I emailed her I
was like you know I got I want to apply
to this internship but like I don't
really meet all the call to shows I'm a
little worried like I don't think I
should do and I don't want to waste
anybody's time at Bob he won't be back
and he said dare to dream and then I
applied and then I got the internship
yes I said dare to dream you just go
hurt I might feel perhaps that you don't
have enough qualifications or enough
background or anything do it
Alfred come welcome to the panicky
snowfalls it
[Music]
you